voici 5 bonnes nouvelles pour la planète
en espagne au portugal le lynx ibérique
a échappé à l'extinction en 2002 cette
espèce avait disparu du portugal et il
en restait moins de 100 individus en
espagne plusieurs mesures ont été mises
en place pour tenter d'enrayer sa
disparition par exemple des lynx élevés
en captivité ont été réintroduits dans
la nature et des parties de leur habitat
ont été reboisés parmi les autres
mesures la construction de tunnels pour
leur permettre de traverser les routes
fréquentées et des campagnes de
sensibilisation pour réduire l'impact de
la chasse aujourd'hui on compterait
environ 1000 lynx ibérique dans
l'ensemble de la péninsule en équateur
dans la forêt amazonienne
un tribunal a ordonné l'arrêt du
torchage de gaz
cette technique consiste à brûler à très
haute température des rejets de gaz
naturel issu de l'exploitation
pétrolière dans le but de les éliminer
m
l'équateur qu'on aurait près de 450
torchère en amazonie depuis début 2000
20 celles ci sont au coeur d'une
bataille juridique entre l'état
équatorien et 9 jeune plaignante
début 2000 21 une cour de justice locale
a finalement ordonné la suspension de
cette pratique l'état équatorien a
ignoré le droit des plaignants à vivre
dans un environnement sain et
écologiquement équilibré en négligeant
avec l'activité pos lui entre leur droit
à la santé en ne fournissant ni en
autres mouvances l'utilisation de
technologies respectueuses de
l'environnement
les plaignants et leurs avocats
demandent que les autorités précisent
quand et comment cette décision va être
appliquée selon la cour de justice
la fin du torchage pourrait réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'équateur d'au moins 24 % en europe la
crise du coït 19 accélère fortement le
développement du vélo
en réaction à la pandémie plus de 1400
km d'infrastructures cyclables ont été
créés dans les villes européennes et
plus d'un milliard d'euros investis
[Musique]
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
londres a entamé la construction de 100
km de pistes cyclables en moins de deux
ans le cyclisme a augmenté de 22% dans
la périphérie de la ville
à paris l'utilisation du vélo a augmenté
de 70% depuis le printemps 2020 et 50 km
de pistes temporaires doivent être
rendues permanente dans le cadre de sa
relance l'italie prévoit d'investir dans
plus de 1000 km de pistes cyclables
urbaine
1600 km de voie touristique en indonésie
c'est historique
le pays a connu son plus bas niveau de
déforestation depuis les premiers suivis
en 1990 en 2020 1150 kilomètres carrés
de forêts ont été perdus à travers le
pays ces 75 % de moins qu'en 2019 et
près de dix fois moins qu'en 2014 2015
pour le gouvernement indonésien cette
baisse est principalement due à des
mesures mises en place comme un
moratoire sur les nouvelles plantations
d'huile de palme
l'interdiction de nouveaux permis pour
défricher des forêts primaires ou encore
l'atténuation des incendies selon le
world kit source institut et d'autres
facteurs ont également joué une année
pluvieuse qui a limité le nombre de feux
la clé sanitaires et la baisse des prix
de l'huile de palme
les engagements du gouvernement à
maintenir un taux de déforestation aussi
bas doivent être tenues ainsi que les
engagements de zéro déforestation du
secteur privé en indonésie la forêt
couvre encore la moitié du pays sur
l'est de bornéo
c'est toi vous n'avez pas été observée
dans la nature depuis plus de 170 ans
las caladas sourcils noirs c'est son nom
avait été découvert entre 1843 et 1848
depuis il n'avait pas été signalé
laissant envisager son extinction en
octobre 2020 deux habitants de bornéo
photographier un oiseau qui ne le
connaissent pas en février 2021
après l'avoir comparée avec l'image du
seul spécimen cognac à la thèse en
chinois des ornithologues ont finalement
conclu qu'il s'agissait bien de la même
espèce
cet oiseau est souvent appelée la plus
grande énigme de l'ornithologie
indonésienne c'était pouces soufflant de
pensée qui n'est pas éteint et qu'il vit
toujours dans ces forêts de plaine
mais c'est aussi un peu effrayant parce
que nous ne savons pas si les oiseaux
sont sûrs ou combien de temps ils
peuvent survivre
[Musique]